[Musique]
puis sous le chaud soleil de la
colombie-britannique
a présentement je me trouve au forum
c'est le pis c'est une réforme le forum
de la paix et de l'unité qui se passe en
territoire où ils souhaitaient ont été
invités sur le territoire par les chefs
traditionnels les chefs ancestraux a
donc j'ai vécu les événements que je
veux partager avec vous cette semaine à
distance mais je les ai vécu je pense
presque aussi intensément
sauf que ça m'a permis d'avoir une
lecture autour de ce que j'ai vécu kaki
est plus profond que l'émotion brute si
j'avais été sur place si j'avais été à
sainte anne de beaupré lors de la visite
du pontife et je vais essayer de
partager avec vous ce que j'ai vu le
mélange je pense des non seulement des
interactions entre les membres des
communautés autochtones aussi je pense
qu'il ya un grand thé veille autour de
ce que ça représente pour les
communautés autochtones est ce que celle
va transformer justement dans l'opinion
des canadiens sur justement les
survivants des pensions alors je vais
essayer de faire ça le court clair mais
quand même très mélangées parce que
c'est pas si jamais ça une visite aussi
grande et surtout avec tous les sujets
qui ont été amenées de l'avant parce que
c'est pas rien que le pape vienne et
s'excuse ça représente quelque chose
d'important mais c'est quand même de une
excuse qu'on a écouté je pense qu'on en
dise que les mots et disques et
l'implication de ce qui a été dit donc
pour ce qui est des excuses du pape
jeudi
il est venu et lui en tant que
représentant de l'église a présenté ses
excuses pour les actions de certains
chrétiens dans les pensionnats pendant
les écoles résidentielles et là nous ce
qu'on lit c'est mon devoir m'excuser
voit la demande de pardon et nous ce
qu'on voit aussi ses excuses pour des
gestes d'individus lui en tant
qu'individu un peu au nom de l'islam est
ce qu'on n'a pas entendu ces et on
s'excuse aussi pour
toutes les actions d'église pour couvrir
ces personnes qui ont fait des gestes
tunnel qui s'est encore présentement une
problématique on n'a pas entendu non
plus sur le retour des territoires et
très particulièrement ce quelque chose
que beaucoup de gens découvrent mais qui
fait partie justement de tout l'ensemble
des problèmes à la base même de
colonisation en afrique du nord et en
amérique du sud c'est la doctrine de la
découverte et terra nullius donc juste
faire ça ça nous prenait grand soin de
parler de sommet en tant que tel c'est
que la doctrine de la découverte et
terra nullius c'est la permission que
l'église a donné d'aller prendre et
coloniser les territoires puisqu'il
était habité par personne qu'ils étaient
de foi chrétienne donc le fait qu'il
n'était pas chrétien validé et renforcer
l'idée vous avez le droit de prendre un
territoire de s'installer et que nos
droits nous c'était juste comme occupant
du territoire juste comme personne qui
était là un peu comme les caribous les
salons et les adaptant donc ça c'était
même si aujourd'hui les tonnes et plus
je suppose et d'être en lien avec
l'église faut se rappeler que quand ça a
commencé la colonisation s'était main
dans la main l'argent qui venait d
église venait aussi des états et donc
c'est ce que fait la base de toute la
colonisation aujourd'hui on sait l'état
est supposé d'être loin de l'église mais
ce n'est pas encore le cas parfaitement
donc de voir
les effets qui arrivent encore
aujourd'hui qui sont encore mis en place
parce que l'église avait permis de faire
c'est pour ça que je parle de ma visite
présentement en territoire est
souhaitable c'est juste vous faire
comprendre qu'
il ya une confusion énorme il ya des
émotions extrêmement puissante qui sont
mélangés pour les personnes qui vivent
et
jeudi toute la journée avant l'arrivée
du pape au québec moi j'étais sur
territoire où est souhaitable et onu
une interaction avec des agents de la
grc
au moment même qu'on arrive à en
territoire on était surveillée on allait
faire une activité de racheter sur la
rivière pour que les boîtes souhaitait
nous fait comprendre l'importance de
leurs rivières et de tout je voyais la
grc qui intervenaient de façon très
musclée très près même elle met de
l'illégal sur le territoire et vous
comprendrez que c'est très personnel
comme interprétation le lendemain
joie une photo de la grc qui escortent
ma grand mère pour aller rencontrer
le pape donc c'est comme si d'une main
ont réconcilié de l'autre ont frappé
c'est qu'il ya encore tellement d'inter
relations dans les problématiques sont
nés de cette relation avec l'église
que maintenant on doit défaire une e de
société mais des fois on sait même pas
que les origines les origines je demande
de ces problématiques donc terra nullius
et la doctrine la découverte qui font
que pendant mon intervention en tant que
témoin afin que les invités sur le
territoire je vois la puissance de la
police d'agir si je te marrante et la
peau c'est quand même la police qui
représente le canada et qui empêche les
personnes autochtones d'être sur leur
territoire et de l'autre le voit
l'église qui essaient de s'excuser pour
ses erreurs du passé et les deux sont
connectés mais les deux ne se parlent
pas et lee agissent
quand même sur un très grand spectre
donc c'est sûr que c'est du sine et le
faire découvrir en plus au grand public
c'est quand même insensé qu'on a vu que
justement une bannière qui a été ouverte
devant le pape pendant la messe et
c'était le stand de doctrine ça veut
dire renier la doctrine donc déjà d'en
parler de faire comprendre l'impact il
l'argent de ce que la doctrine l'a
découvert en fait
c'est quand même un gros d'avoir qui
s'en viennent ou des enjeux c'est
maintenant qu'on a reçu des excuses
beaucoup de gens ont pensé ok on va
passer à autre chose on voit aller de
l'avant avec ça mais il ya encore
beaucoup d'enjeu à de décors qui ont pas
été retrouvée de certains des prêts qui
sont encore en vie qui ont commis des
crimes de pédophilie
mais ça se mélange même temps à régler
gens qui sont extrêmement croyants dans
nos communautés et ce qui est difficile
je suis parti d'une nation qui ont un
respect énorme pour ses aînés et on doit
être capable de naviguer à travers
cette demande justice là en même temps
qu'on veut protéger nos aînés les
respecter
donc on les comprend quand même dans
leurs croyances qui dans leur foi
puisque elle pour certaines certaines
des personnes n ont pas été justement
d'aller vite dans les conteneurs et
leurs croyances et la peau a été mise en
doute la même manière que des survivants
par exemple qui ne se reconnaissent pas
ne reconnaissent pas l'autorité de
l'église et même des survivants qui
reconnaissent l'autorité des devises
mais qui ont été pensés n'a donc vous
comprendrez que le
l'argent
la couverture
qui vient prendre les émotions des
communautés autochtones qui était énorme
et c'est lui aussi qui prime c'est que
je dis communauté autochtone et ça c'est
encore un autre niveau sur
l'interprétation qu'on va avoir de ce
qui s'est passé parce que communauté
autochtone c'est encore comme dire les
indiens mais de manière plus polie un
jour on va dire ok les gens de la
communauté de conduite par exemple ont
réagi de cette manière les gens de la
communauté de cannes et starsky
kahnawake ont réagi notre manière et
pour l'instant on est encore un panier
mix et les gens essaient de démêler les
deux nations donc on est en train de
voir une lecture beaucoup plus pour moi
personnellement beaucoup plus
respectueuse de ce qui s'est passé on
écoute beaucoup plus les survivants les
enfants des survivants dont 11 à faire
de distinction entre les gros cependant
c'est encore en progrès et en plus
les médias sont en éducation justement
de principes tels que la doctrine la
découverte la déclaration de l'onu sur
les droits des peuples autochtones et
même les gens de notre communauté sont
en train d'aider pouvoir parce que je
peux vous le promettre ils nous ont pas
enseigner la loi sur des indiens on ne
peut pas enseigner nos droits quand on
était à l'école dans nos communautés
c'est des informations qu'on commence à
avoir cessé d information qui nous était
enseigné à l'université ou au cégep et
même encore là certaines des enseignants
qui les enseignants eux-mêmes connaissez
pas toujours toute information sur les
sujets dont le canada apprend à mesure
voir la visite du pape quand même et
voit que c'est une reconnaissance de
l'erreur qui a été faite envers les
communautés donc au moins
quand on dit que il invente c'était
malheureusement des arguments
j'attendais ça il invente exagère val
d'argent mais l'église vient elle-même
faire visite en territoire pour pouvoir
s'excuser c'est une reconnaissance quand
même que le mensonge c'est pas la
problématique des enjeux les enfants des
pensionnés donc vous comprendrez que
c'est extrêmement émotionnelles
généralement pleurer
et je me suis tourné beaucoup vers les
élites qui se trouvant que les pas au
dessous et âme pour m'inspirer mais plus
particulièrement ma mère qui elle aussi
est une survivante et
on est
une force qui m'inspire moi en tant
qu'enfant des générations suivantes donc
c'est un sujet et une visite extrêmement
émotionnelles
je peux vous le dire que ça le fait on a
fait attention aussi comme on parlait
comme on disait les choses en font c'est
aussi qu'on peut pas s'exprimer de la
même manière sur les plateformes
médiatiques qu'un canadien ou québécois
par exemple parce que on risque d'avoir
des attaques latérales et c'est là où
est ce que beaucoup beaucoup de travail
que nos alliés et nous nos complices
justement jeudi complice pas assez des
gens qui s'impliquent qui disent non
arrêtez de dire des mensonges sur les
communautés quand elle et elle partage
leur douleur donc c'est un moment
transforme à terme c'est pas une
question qui est finie c'est quelque
chose que vous allez entendre qui va
amener à une discussion future sur
d'autres enjeux
et donc il va falloir qu'on parle du
rapatriement des objets culturels sur la
compa aussi du fait de telle église
encore une propriétaire en propriétaires
de terrains et est ce que certains
territoires là vont être ordonnés à des
communautés en excuses on va parler
aussi du fait que la visite du pape au
foot et énormément engagé le canada vers
des dépenses pour faire en sorte que le
pape puisse venir visiter de façon
sécuritaire alors que c'est des travaux
qui auraient pu être faite bien avant un
communauté mais on répondait jamais la
demande donc c'est de voir aussi encore
le débat lancement qui existe entre la
relation du canada citoyens de donner
les autres sites web alors je vous
remercie beaucoup votre patience je sais
que c'est une longue chronique je sais
que c'est très mélangeant des fois aussi
quand on parle de quelque chose qui est
tellement grand angle mais ça c'est pour
vous intéresser justement autour des
enjeux c'est pour voir aussi comment
on doit en même temps de guérir on doit
lutter pour nos droits donc sais c'est
pas tout le temps évident mais on ne
lâche pas la bonne bataille puisque on
est là
pour des milliers d'années
je vous souhaite une très belle semaine
je vous souhaite beaucoup de guérison je
souhaite justement de bâtir la
réconciliation avec les membres de votre
communauté et de les encourager à faire
aussi
cette prise de parole qui est très
nécessaire pour que le canada puisse
apprendre plus sur l'humain ben joue cet
universel